c'est à vous en direct jusqu'à 20h 55
avec marion pierre patrick playback pas
d'éléphants rouflaquettes les costumes
blancs micro tenue du bout des doigts en
éloignant le micro du bout des doigts je
le répète j'ai foiré
43,2 degrés c'est la température la plus
élevée relevé à belin-béliet en gironde
un record absolu de température sous
abri suivent pissos avec 43 degrés
biarritz avec 42,9 tout comme
cambo-les-bains aujourd'hui plus de 150
records de chaleur mensuelles ont été
battus et maman ma vie ces empreintes de
froid dehors
vous voulez parce que si jamais très
agréable douche froide à part si quatre
étages tachot le hellfest n'a jamais
aussi bien porté son nom 39 degrés
atteints cet après midi au festival de
l'enfer c'est génial ses crocs revenir
là on est vraiment vraiment en faire et
c'est bonnard pour se rafraîchir tant
bien que mal les plus téméraires n'ont
pas peur de prendre une douche froide
c'est nickel saloperie aussi parce que
vu la température qui paie
combien hype équipe à trois quand même
ça veut dire qu'on est là veut dire quoi
j'ai pris une douche froide c est ce que
ça veut dire en gros que je vais déjà eu
un coup de coeur pour toi elle a fait
l'orgueil savait pas alors conférence
parce que ça fait six mois si tu vois
pas des chats tu les vois plus douche
froide c'est un bon genre nom d'espacé
et s'est pris un vent en fait bonjour
ici on peut manger aussi même le soir
d'accord de quoi du boulet
alors
c'est le nom qu'on est là où on
attendait ouest apprend que tu as dis
pas plus mais si promis à tabac par ok
ok ok ok beauté c'est entendu
verser le tout on n'a pas la route oui
ok il est à la voilà c'est fini c'est
fini c'est mon chien non il va aller
normalement
ce qui se trame et là il va vers porte
de la chapelle
deux chiens
bébé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il me semble c'est sur une idée des
carpentier que gainsbourg a écrit et
poupée de cire poupée de son pour france
gall et je pense que je dis peut-être
une bêtise mais peut-être que non
ces
avancées ont peut-être mais peut-être
non alors mon fils quand on vraiment se
positionne au fameux mal on trade a
promis à ses côtés
chiens de me casser la figure je me suis
tordu la cheville violemment
fait une entorse ans et c'est sûr bah
ouais ça va aller à peu près ça c'est
encore chaud mais tout à l'heure ça va
plus aller du tout
rester gonfler un peu ça va aux etats
unis plus de peur que de mal pour joe
biden regarder le président américain
fait une chute à vélo lors d'une balade
dans le de labouheyre où il passe le
week end il est tombé à l'arrêt il s'est
très vite relevé assurant qu'il allait
bien après une courte discussion avec
les passants il est reparti sur son vélo
nous voilà rassurés vous ne pensez qu'il
faut mettre des broches deyris viennent
pas compromettre
la concertation
bon ben on fera ça à paris
c'est en jeu
et c'est comme ça que j'ai été rapatrié
la première fois après 40 ans de voyage
c'est bien le noter effectivement
je continue babet bah oui bah sinon
personne parle général 2e 2e annick de
bizarre cette émission y arriver les
blancs oui c'est ce qui se passe c'est
vraiment ma responsabilité
attention ces trois fruits sans la
lettre à
anna
connais-tu des pères
moi j'ai trouvé ça plutôt rigolo d'abord
parce que le médecin a été vachement
sympa et puis surtout on s'occupe de toi
t'as peut rien à gérer tu es devenu un
colis presque à la limite et puis on
s'est bien amusé parce que dans
l'aéroport on n'a pas réussi à trouver
chaise roulante donc on s'est débrouillé
avec les moyens du bord enfin bref je
suis rentré à paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est en train de parler de toute une
génération qui va mourir parce qu'elle
pourra plus se nourrir il est en train
de parler de pas prendre la tête à moi
la miss k
mais bien sûr mais moi j'adore les
brigades
on peut pas nous qui allons regarder ça
c'est certain mais je suis là pour ça
que tu vas mourir moi je vais vous
réalité en fait
sans âme sans soucis sans prothèse